- [David] Hello, readers.
Let's argue.
In writing, argument is a kind of fight.
But I think it is unwise
to think of it as a one-way conversation.
The best arguments do not
plunge forward heedlessly.
They do not steamroll opposition.
Rather, they seek out opposing arguments
and incorporate them.
Good readers pay attention
to how authors acknowledge
opposing viewpoints in an argument.
Doing this makes it easier to decide
how well thought out an argument is
and determine whether the
author is knowledgeable
and thoughtful in their position.
Now, I do not practice the
martial art of Wing Chun.
But that style of self-defense
is famous for techniques
that block and strike at the same time.
Your opponent's fist comes in,
you redirect it away from your body,
and in that same motion
continue your momentum
into its own immediate counterstrike.
Acknowledging the existence
of opposing viewpoints
has two main applications,
which are pretty different.
First, maybe you're not on
any side of the argument
and you wish to straightforwardly
describe the conflict,
like a journalist reporting on a lawsuit.
It's a journalist's responsibility
to truthfully portray the
full scope of information
on a topic, bringing
every piece of relevant
and plausible information to bear.
The author provides equal
time to the disputants
and tries not to provide
their own opinion here.
That could look like this.
Ms. Adeyemi contended that
Mr. Dupont stole the cookies
from her cookie jar, and that furthermore,
she had baked those
cookies in the first place,
thus strengthening her
claim to the said cookies.
Of the 24 cookies baked by Ms. Adeyemi,
she alleges that 10 of them
were taken by Mr. Dupont.
Mr. Dupont, however, contended
that as he was the person
who made the cookie jar for Ms. Adeyemi
in the ceramics class he took,
he is entitled to the occasional cookie.
He does not dispute the 10-cookie figure,
adding only that they were "delicious."
Judge Huang, upon reviewing
testimony from both parties,
sided with Ms. Adeyemi,
saying that you are not
entitled to a cookie
just for being a good friend one time,
and that next time, Mr. Dupont
should ask for permission.
Now, looking at that situation,
my personal opinion is
that it is inappropriate
to steal your friend's cookies.
An opinion that any right-thinking
person should share.
But injecting opinion may not
be appropriate in all cases.
So okay, that's the first case.
Reporting on multiple sides of a dispute
without getting involved yourself.
Now, the second reason,
the second application for
including opposing viewpoints
in an argumentative piece of writing
is that Wing Chun thing, the
block as you strike technique.
It makes your argument stronger
if you anticipate
possible objections to it,
address them, and strike them down
all the while still making your
argument in the first place.
Let's take this example from the website.
This piece is about the
lost colony at Roanoke.
A bunch of English settlers disappeared
under uncertain circumstances
for reasons still unknown.
And the author's trying to make the case
that although theories for
the disappearance exist,
the truth is still beyond our grasp.
So in order to make that case,
they address several different theories
that attempt to explain the disappearance.
Many people have tried
to solve the mystery
of the lost colony.
Historians and archeologists
have searched for answers
for hundreds of years.
Some possible solutions are:
A, Native people killed the
colonists on Roanoke Island.
B, the colonists were all killed
on Roanoke Island by disease.
C, their town was washed
away by a hurricane,
and the people drowned.
Or D, they all left Roanoke Island
and went to live in some other place.
Now, watch what the author
does as they systematically
go through each theory and address it.
I've only excepted the first two,
so let's look at those first two.
A, when John White got back
to Roanoke Island in 1590
he did not find any bones or bodies
or any signs of fighting.
Bones last a long time.
If Native people had killed the colonists,
there would probably
have been some remains
or other signs of violence.
We can guess that the colonists
were not killed on Roanoke Island.
B, when the English
first came to Virginia,
they're using a 16th-century spelling,
they brought diseases with
them, such as flu and smallpox,
that were new to the Native communities.
They had no immunity against them
and many died very quickly.
Letters written by the colonists
tell us that the English remained healthy.
And remember, no bones or
bodies or graves were found.
We can guess that the colonists
did not all die of disease.
So the author's saying that
these events are unlikely,
taking the theories seriously,
and then thinking them
through to their conclusions.
But demonstrating why they don't seem
very likely explanations.
Why do they think it's unlikely
that Native people killed those colonists?
There aren't any remains
or signs of combat.
Why does it seem unlikely
that they died of diseases?
There are no graves or remains.
The thesis is, nobody knows why.
Here are two counters to it
basically saying here's why,
and the author says here's why
these are unlikely to be true
which weakens those counterarguments
and strengthens the original.
Block, strike.
My overall point is this.
Don't ignore the potential
counters to your argument.
Incorporate them, analyze them,
and redirect their energy
into your own position.
And when you read,
notice if the author is
acknowledging counters
or ignoring them.
If they ignore them, you
should be suspicious.
Why are they ignoring them?
If you can answer that,
then you can learn anything.
David out.